pour laisser d'américains vote des
sanctions économiques contre l'afrique
du sud et son régime raciste
le peso mexique à l'évaluer de 40% le
prix du pétrole va s'en ressentir
l'inserm a 20 ans moyens réduits mais
résultats excellents de la cité de
recherche médicale bougez midi film de
robert guédiguian le cinéma français sur
le registre régional
mesdames messieurs bonsoir
faut-il ou non prendre des sanctions
contre le régime raciste d'afrique du
sud
c'est le débat qui agite en ce moment
les états unis le président reagan a
même sa majorité contre lui puisque le
sénat dominé par les républicains a voté
la nuit dernière des sanctions
économiques contre l'afrique du sud
nous sommes contre ces sanctions a
immédiatement fait savoir la maison
blanche
quant à l'afrique du sud elle n'y croit
guère mémona hintermann voici les images
d'afrique du sud que les américains ne
veulent plus supporter celle d'hommes et
de femmes méprisés ou tuer parce qu'ils
sont noirs
depuis des mois le poids de l'opinion
publique américaine agit sur la place
politique
l'offensive a été menée à la chambre des
représentants d'abord par des
parlementaires noirs
elle a été relayées quotidiennement à la
une par les médias avant de se
concrétiser hier soir pour la première
fois au sénat y compris par les
partisans du président américain
des sanctions limitées interdiction
d'exportation de matériels informatiques
vers l'afrique du sud
blocage de prêts bancaires au
gouvernement sud-africain fin de la
coopération nucléaire commercial ces
sanctions seraient aggravées dans 18
mois
je veux respirer d'être il est dit que
le message du sénat américain de la nuit
dernière sera clair pour le reste du
monde les etats-unis n'apporteront plus
leur soutien au régime ans et à la
politique d'apartheid
ils cesseront leur ait des sanctions
veulent punir et ça retarde la
croissance économique et ça risque de
faire d'avoir un effet que les blancs se
braque
donc à mon avis ces sanctions s'ils vont
plus loin surtout sont tout à fait
contre productif
il faut que le marché sud-africain
s'élargit
il faut que les talents qui soit blanc
noir ou un autre soit bien utilisé et
pour toutes ces raisons là on est pour
la démantèlement graduel sur une voie
d'évolution de démantèlement de
l'apartheid
vous dites graduelle mais ce n'est pas
trop tard non on peut jamais dire que
c'est trop tard
si on dit que c'est trop tard qu'est ce
qu'on veut une révolution une politique
de table rase une politique des tables
rases n'a pas très bien marché dans
beaucoup d'autres parties du monde et je
crois vraiment que l'afrique du sud est
le moteur du progrès économique de
toutes les moitié sud de l'afrique alors
faire table rase en afrique du sud ça
aurait des conséquences énormes pas
seulement sur les pays voisins mais sur
certains pays en europe où on dépend
beaucoup des matières premières
important qui vient l'afrique du sud en
tant que sud africain anton com
etes-vous favorable l'apartheid
non je ne suis pas favorable appart est
alors beaucoup des gens sont contre
l'apartheid la différence et comment
comment faire écarter l'apartheid
il faut le faire à mon avis de plus en
plus vite
mais dans l'ordre et suivant une
politique d'évolution et ne pas
favoriser ce que pourrait être une
révolution
le mexique vient de dévaluer sa monnaie
le peso de 40%
une mesure dont les conséquences
dépassent le cadre national mexicain
cela influe en particulier sur le prix
du pétrole mexicain mais cela pourrait
avoir des répercussions sur l'ensemble
des cours du pétrole et cela vise en
premier les pays de l'opep
pierre babey le peso brûle les doigts à
mexico ce mauvais titres de romans
policiers est une réalité aujourd'hui
sur tous les marchés monétaires mexicain
officiel libre ou clandestins ici à
l'aéroport au lieu des transactions
discrète
il faut désormais 40% de pesos en plus
pour acheter le même billet vert dans le
même temps le brut décroche de la grille
au peuple que le mexique suivait sans y
être contraint la contagion de la baisse
pourrait se propager rapidement aux
autres producteurs changements de
parités besse ii
revenus pétroliers vont contribuer de
dévasté l'économie mexicaine et
notamment relancer l'immigration
clandestine à destination de l'eldorado
américain le long de milliers de
kilomètres de frontière avec les états
unis
pourtant sévèrement gardée mais c'est
dans les bidonvilles que la rigueur à la
mexicaine sera encore plus inhumaine le
manque à gagner dû à la baisse des prix
pétroliers va coûter au pays près de 12
milliards de francs
en 1985 on pensait pourtant que le seuil
inférieur de pauvreté était déjà atteint
depuis longtemps
l'organisation des brigades
révolutionnaires arabes a revendiqué les
deux attentats qui ont fait 11 morts et
89 blessés hier soir au koweït
cette organisation a déjà revendiqué
plusieurs attentats au corps est
toujours francine raymond le pouvait a
connu hier l'attentât le plus meurtrier
de son histoire deux bombes de forte
puissance qui ont explosé simultanément
dans deux cafés populaires du front de
mer
un deuil national a été décrété parmi
les onze victimes de ce double attentat
se trouvait le colonel al abdallah un
responsable du ministère de la défense
directement visé l'organisation des
brigades révolutionnaires arabes qui
revendique l'attentât indiqué que son
exécution était lié aux mesures
d'expulsion et de déportation qu'il
avait prise et mettait en garde le co
est contre la poursuite de sa politique
hostile aux citoyens arabes et
palestiniens depuis deux ans le koweït a
multiplié les mesures de sécurité pour
lutter contre le terrorisme
en expulsant de l'émirat toute personne
jugée dangereuse mesures renforcées
surtout après la tentative d'assassinât
de l' émir le cheikh jaber al sabah qui
avaient fait cinq victimes attentats
revendiqués par le djihad islamique
l'organisation intégriste voulait
obtenir la libération des auteurs
d'attentats contre les ambassades de
france et des états unis condamnés à de
lourdes peines de prison
les dirigeants du coa et ont toujours
refusé de céder au chantage du jihad
islamique
aujourd'hui encore ils ont redit qu'ils
ne se laisseraient pas intimider par le
terrorisme la menace de l'intégrisme
musulman pèse sur tous les pays de la
région y compris les pays les plus
démocratiques comme le koweït ou
l'egypte au koweït on vient de le voir
la menace est plus que précise avec des
attentats en série
en egypte les autorités sont des
idées à prendre les devants au point que
les intégristes ont renoncé à la
manifestation qu'il voulait organiser
aujourd'hui au caire joël hasard pour
l'heure en egypte c'est un bras de fer
qui oppose les autorités les intégristes
musulmans
mais l'épreuve de force risque d'être
pour demain disparue des lieux publics
après l'assassinât du président sadate
les islamistes durs sont de retour au
caire
si c'est un motard bouche rouge et blanc
le cheikh salah malheur guide spirituel
a pignon sur rue les activistes
musulmans restent dans l'ombre prêt à
frapper le moment venu devant la
détermination des autorités
il semble marquer le pas mais ils sont
tout de même descendus dans la rue pour
réclamer l'application immédiate de la
loi islamique charia auprès de levier
mire des frères musulmans au martel
messani apparaît comme un modéré
les intégristes la cus d'ailleurs de
complaisance à l'égard du régime pour le
peuple intégré sous frères musulmans
c'est la même chose mais le pouvoir lui
est différent si qui voit dans les
intégrer des agents manipuler
d'extérieur libye ou l'iran les
intégristes s'en prennent aussi aux
coptes orthodoxes leur établissement sur
le trône de saint marc du pape chénouda
iii a été dénoncé par eux comme une
marque de honte sur le front du régime
face à cette percée de l'intolérance
assauts pression pour islamiser le
régime
le pouvoir égyptien a pratiqué
l'ouverture à l'islam modéré et frères
musulmans sont présentés au parlement
et si le débat sur la charia a peut être
escamotée les autorités ont dû faire des
concessions notamment sur les droits des
femmes politique de clémence à l'égard
des frères musulmans
nombre d'entre eux ont été graciés mais
pour les intégrer ce n'est pas assez
le résultat de ces compromis est visible
au quotidien
en fait quand de plus en plus les
mosquées le ramadan est fait
scrupuleusement imposée respecter les
femmes sont de plus en plus nombreuses à
porter le voile dans les classes
sociales les plus défavorisées ou à
l'université président moubarak a choisi
de tenir compte des revendications
populaires
mais il risque aussi de glisser
doucement vers une islamisation complète
du régime
s'il n'y prend garde aussi semble-t-il
avoir enfin décidé de faire front
aujourd'hui encore en france les états
majors politiques commente mais surtout
s'interroge sur les intentions du
président mitterrand sur le fameux
problème de la cohabitation
après les indications qu'il a lui-même
fourni mercredi mais michel naudy en
saura peut-être plus dimanche puisqu'on
prête au président l'attention de
préciser probablement sa pensée en effet
oui il est toujours aventureux de
prendre un propos de pure circonstance
pour une théorie de l'état
et c'est peut-être là la leçon qu'on
retiendra de toute la polémique qui
agite le monde politique depuis
maintenant deux jours sans doute le
convive de grenoble monsieur mitterrand
n'est-il pas le premier venu mais de là
à considérer qu'il a choisi cette
circonstance et le détour d'une phrase
pour exprimer sa conception de la
répartition de pouvoir et sa lecture de
la constitution il ya peut être un pas
un trop grand pas sans doute d'autant
que se disant on ne voit pas très bien
le but corey poursuivi le président de
la république
en effet en se plaçant uniquement dans
l'hypothèse d'une victoire de la droite
il prend le risque de démobiliser son
propre électorat et de donner des
arguments supplémentaires aux
particuliers si lui en fallait par
ailleurs en reprenant la thèse du
domaine réservé il donne là un argument
de poids à monsieur bart dans sa
croisade contre la cohabitation deux
effets induits qui ne lui ont guère
favorable c'est le moins que l'on puisse
dire c'est pourquoi il nous envoûte
battre inutile de prendre son temps
avant de se faire une religion
d'autant que françois mitterrand ne
devrait pas manquer d'évoquer de
préciser d'affaires le 14 juillet en
tout cas il faut s'en souvenir en a
rarement vu un général partir en
campagne en dévoilant à ses troupes et à
l'adversaire son plan de retraite à
l'occasion du 14 juillet 2004 100
détenus seront libérés par une grâce
présidentielle ils bénéficieront d'une
remise de peine d'un à deux mois
1500 qui devait sortir le 15 août et 900
sur proposition du juge d'application
des peines qui devait sortir entre
l'occasion
et le 15 septembre sont exclus de cette
remise de peine est détenu condamné pour
proxénétisme trafic de drogue violence
contre des agents de la force publique
contre des agents pénitentiaires
ce sera la première grâce présidentielle
depuis 1980 le chef de l'état devrait
également annoncé le renforcement des
effectifs pénitentiaire et
l'amélioration d'un retrait des
surveillants six membres de la famille
villemin
c'est quand les grands parents du petit
grégory cédant parents paternels et
quatre de ses oncles et tantes se sont
portées parties civiles cela leur
permettra d'abord d'avoir accès au
dossier
ainsi lundi à sisteron il à l'audience
de la cour d'appel qui examinera la
demande de mise en liberté de christine
villemin
le premier ministre japonais n'a qu'a
sonné commence demain en france une
tournée européenne de dix jours
objectif renforcer les liens entre le
japon et l'europe pour faire un peu
contrepoids aux rapports privilégiés
qu'il entretient avec les états unis
il s'agit aussi pour le premier ministre
japonais de plaider la cause un pays
jugé un peu trop entreprenant et trop
protectionniste par les européens hubert
coudurier au pouvoir depuis 1982 et
yasuhiro nakasone et est dépeint comme
un conservateur énergique d'où ses liens
étroits avec le président reagan et la
volonté que son pays ne demeurent pas
éternellement 1-1 politique
certes la puissance technologique
japonaise a été parfaitement illustré
cette année par l'exposition de tsukuba
un symbole évident de savoir faire dans
le domaine des produits à forte valeur
ajoutée doublée d'une vaste offensive
commerciale sur le marché européen cette
politique a engendré un déficit des
échanges pour la communauté de 100
milliards de francs car les frontières
nippones ne sont pas elles très
perméable aux produits du vieux
continent les barrières tarifaires la
complexité des réglementations
autant de signes du protectionnisme
japonais une mauvaise volonté qui irrite
les européens dont le ton est monté lors
des récents sommets
c'est pourquoi le japon annoncent
régulièrement des mesures d'ouverture de
son marché qui ne sont guère mise en
oeuvre par l'administration
la france a tout de même réussi à
développer sa présence au pays du soleil
levant tout en attirant dans l'hexagone
des industriels nippons témoins lusine
cannon près de rennes qui vit désormais
à l'heure orientale reste néanmoins au
japon à démontrer sa solidarité
effective
avec l'occident l'inserm institut
national d'études et de recherches
médicales célèbre ses 20 ans d'existence
dans son bilan annuel on trouve
l'ouverture à des sociétés privées
l'intermezzo remet a autorisé à y
prendre des participations
mais pour être compétitif on resserre
les rangs 30 unités de recherche
supprimés en trois ans d'ailleurs
critique les 3000 personnes qui
travaillent à l'inserm chercheurs et
techniciens administratifs conclu à la
très haute qualité des résultats
aurore molinero derrière ces murs
grisâtre le top niveau de la recherche
médicale
nous en avons choisi deux dans ce qu'on
appelle les créneaux privilégié coeur et
immunologie ici c'est alain dans l'unité
de recherche est à lariboisière
objectif étudier un des très nombreux
facteurs qui conduisent à
l'athérosclérose pour la combattre une
petite pierre comme il dit dans le grand
est déficiente ific
hélas la fondation de curry c'est
catherine immunologue qui s'acharnent à
comprendre pour nous et à vaincre tous
qui attaque le corps mais c'était
recruter relativement rapidement mises
en situations de couper difficile où
dame il ya beaucoup d'étudiants il ya
peu de beauce est aussi et surtout il ya
très peu de postes de chercheurs et pour
eux c'est toujours très difficile la
sélection est beaucoup plus drastiques
mamans qui allaitaient ya quinze ans
c'est tout le problème du pain de nombre
de postes au recrutement
s'il y avait suffisamment de postes
recrutement j'imagine que les problèmes
seraient beaucoup moins vécu toute
personne ayant un dossier inconvenable
scientifiquement pourrait être recruté
les critères d'évaluation dur au niveau
du recrutement
mais je crois qu'ils sont ils sont à peu
près les mêmes que les critères
d'évaluation de sanctions du travail
pour un chercheur déjà recruté c'est à
dire que c'est celui de se confronter
encore une fois aux autres chercheurs
travaillant sur ce sujet est de savoir
si il apporte une petite pierre a fait
rechercher la est de savoir si il est
reconnu entre guillemets dans la
communauté internationale et dans sa
discipline
mais pour être reconnu dans sa
discipline il faut faire connaître
d'abord ses recherches il faut publier
des articles
facile quand on fait de la recherche en
france parce que il ya un impérialisme
américain notoire au niveau des
publications par exemple tous les grands
journaux d'immunologie sont des journaux
publiés aux états unis
là il ya un lobby très très important
mais on en fait
ces brouilles et intellectuellement on
peut tenir
bah oui les revues de niveau
international sont bien souvent on peut
le déplorer c'était une état de fait des
revues de langue anglaise est en général
américaine bon et bien fait une donnée
il faut faire avec
les chercheurs les pas de chercheurs
français sont capables et peuvent et
publie d'ailleurs dans des revues
américain critique est optimiste
derrière tout l'appareillage qui nous
emprisonnent et nous sauf parfois
l'hôpital ils sont là
15 261 chercheurs sur les 3000 et
quelques scientifiques de l'inserm un
institut de pointe qui resserre les
rangs supprime des unités de recherche
30 en trois ans mais atteint le plus
souvent la compétitivité réel à
l'échelon mondial le niveau d'excellence
comme il vise cinéma rouge midi film de
robert guédiguian raconte l'histoire de
quatre générations d'italiens émigré en
france dans le quartier populaire de
l'estaque à marseille dans les années 20
on remarquera que la sortie du film n'a
pas été parisienne cela arrive le film a
d'abord été présenté à marseille là où
il a été tourné en voici quelques images
le rôle de macho rina l'héroïne de cette
chronique est interprété par ariane
ascaride
tirage étant sous l'initiale mater diop
s'est plu à peine d'essayer de remettre
les pieds chez moi je ne serais pas
rentré
rajoelina qu'est-ce qui attend presque
choqué jean et je suis sûr que tu pas de
coeur jolin
écoutez moi je vais t'expliquer comment
expliquer que tu veux c'est ginette un
kill
je te promets je n'arrivais plus à ce
que je n'aime pas c'est toi que j'ai un
film tourné à marseille présenté à
marseille est ce qu'on peut imaginer un
cinéma régional comme celui des italiens
par exemple les sapiens mais je crois
que robert guédiguian le prouve là tout
à fait évidemment on en a vus minutes
mais si vous voulez servir très
captivant parce qu'en général en france
on a comme une as you need est accepté
on se dit la classe ouvrière me touche
pas parce que c'est didactique c'est
difficile il faudrait expliquer on ne
connaît pas pratiquement c'est pas vrai
du cinéma français d'avant guerre ce
phénomène curieux ces phénomènes date
peut-être des années 60 est là
brusquement ya réveil et c'est dans le
midi de la france etc régional dans le
sens de la culture et de la réalité
aussi parce que dans les années 20
marseille ça a été la vague italienne
on a oublié qu'ils ont dû les problèmes
on a oublié
ils ont d'immenses problèmes d'ailleurs
la famille d'yves montand notamment son
frère l'avait raconté au cours d'une
émission
le film lui raconte à la fois laventure
la passion des italiens qui étaient des
calabrais et c'était aussi des gens
évidemment de gauche des gens motivés
par l'instinct de classe par l'élu de
l'époque 36
ensuite la guerre ensuite l'après guerre
est chaque fois l'illusion du monde
heureux et puis finalement j'abrège ça
se termine d'une manière un tout petit
peu désenchanté puisque le dernier
maillot
la chaîne eh bien il vient à paris et là
attention on sent qu'on nous dit
n'abandonnez pas votre culture résister
ce que vous êtes et ne devenait pas
n'importe qui et c'est important ce
message là aujourd'hui une des nouvelles
de la navette spatiale américaine
challenger qui devait s'envoler en ce
moment même des de la base américaine de
cap canaveral est bien le compte à
rebours vient d'être interrompu pendant
quelques quelques secondes avant le
lancement de la navette challenger je
découvre la formation même temps que je
vous la livre
les ordinateurs ont détecté une anomalie
et ont arrêté les moteurs de la navette
dont l'allumage avait commencé et on
ignore pour le moment les raisons de cet
incident si par hasard nous les avons
d'ici la fin du journal bien entendu je
vous les donnerais en attendant des
nouvelles du dollar est bien le baisse
de la monnaie américaine fait plus que
se confirmer 882 aujourd'hui à paris il
a plongé de 13 centimes martin thibault
s'est confirmée le dollar est maintenant
bien parti pour baisser et cela finit
par inquiéter les détenteurs de taulard
du monde entier aucune des informations
économiques attendues aujourd'hui n'est
venu les réconforter à paris les
optimistes avaient raison de l'être
en cette veille de week end prolongé et
pour la troisième séance consécutive
les valeurs françaises ont progressé les
investisseurs anticipent en effet une
réduction du taux de base bancaire
les jours se suivent et ne se
ressemblent pas si hier soir à wall
street on a battu un nouveau record
ce soir on reprend son rebond dans un
marché assez peu animé d'autant que les
grandes valeurs ont du mal à suivre le
rythme à tiercé demain à maisons
laffitte dans le prix de but
les pronostics de monsieur courtine sur
les 21 partants il a choisi les numéros
1 5 c'est son joker 7 14 21 10 et 4 le
temps demain pour terminer il a fait
lourd aujourd'hui alors il faut donc
s'attendre à des orages d'abord sur le
sud ouest et ensuite sur toute la moitié
ouest avant et après les orages du
soleil sauf près de la manche vous voyez
où il y aura des nuages toute la matinée
les températures
les températures sont des températures
tout à fait estivale fonds dépassent
largement les 30 degrés dans le sud
ouest
demain soir nous avons rendez-vous à
21h35 dans quelques instants spéciale
tropiques le festival musical
d'angoulême avant de nous quitter
le rappel des titres de ce journal à
demain soir
le sénat américain vote des sanctions
économiques contre l'afrique du sud et
son régime raciste
le peso mexicain d'évaluer de 40% le
prix du pétrole va s'en ressentir bien
le premier ministre japonais demain en
france première étape d'une tournée
européenne de dix jours